the jurogan experience last uh
tapes uh tape study we actually watched
uh diego sanchez fighting nick diaz in
the ufc
because there was a lot of up and down
scrimmaging where diego had to take down
nick would go for a submission and then
they would always end up on top and john
just
builds this habit of uh we call a hustle
till you score where you just don't stop
moving until you get to a score
and
it just completely changed the way that
you know we all think about the agcc
scoring criteria and and how how to play
the game
how does john maintain his motivation
dude
i wish i could tell you
um
he's just been doing the same thing for
30 years he just
he loves it i mean i i wish i had like
half the dedication and like interest in
jiu jitsu that john has and
i mean i'm
probably i'm the most dedicated athlete
i would say to jiu jitsu and it's still
just pales in comparison like we're
podcasting right now john's like
watching like a 1957 boxing match or
like the semi-finals from like the 1960
like judo olympics like it's insane
it's just
most people
when they work really hard towards
something they get a personal reward for
it like i mean he's recognized widely as
one of the greatest jiu jitsu trainers
of all time but like
it's not like the guy gets a lot of like
personal
satisfaction there's not like a lot of
people like heaping praise on him it's
not that's not his motivation which is
so interesting to be that dedic like you
get a lot of praise like you you're the
guy who you're when felipe quit and then
you [ __ ] walk around with a big smile
on your face or when you
write down on a piece of paper they're
going to submit wagner rocha with a
triangle and then you go and do it like
you're getting like that feeling out of
your own personal satisfaction your own
personal accomplishment achievement he's
not even getting that he's getting it
from other people's achievements he's so
dedicated he's really selfless i mean he
doesn't ask me he literally doesn't ask
us for anything no money no nothing he
just wants you to show up to training
but i think he gets a lot of
satisfaction from building athletes and
seeing them succeed with the stuff that
he teaches
and i think that's that's where his
happiness comes from is just seeing like
when i like win avcc or i do something
big like
you can tell he's like very very
happy that's like one thing that
genuinely makes them happy
i remember with john like when we i used
to train with him for about a year when
they were uh in puerto rico
and you know most instructors they'll
just come like the standard is 30-minute
warm-up three techniques and then you
roll for 30 minutes so me and john would
actually hang out after class all the
time he'd just come over we'd get some
food
he'd always be watching tape and then
he'd always be making notes he'd make a
program for a week he'd always have a
goal one week one month three months and
he would just go and apply that um every
day in class so
you know that's all he does is dedicate
himself to his craft um and you see the
results there's no one like him no one
else does that and he doesn't do
anything else in life like
he bought enough he has an apartment now
and uh
i'm like hey do you go like furniture
shopping you like get like plates and
dishes he's like um i have to do that
i'm like we've been living here for a
year dude i had to go to [ __ ] bed
bath and beyond last week to pick him up
plates bowls
dishes
what does he eat
uh take care so he fasts and he just
goes he just goes to uh to whole foods
at the end of the day and picks up whole
foods hits on chicks
and uh
but he like doesn't have like i i helped
him move into his apartment it's like no
one's been ever been in like any of
john's apartments so i helped him move
into the apartment so he's got like some
furniture he's got like a bed
and like a couch and stuff and he's
going to need to put some furniture in
here i'm like yeah that's never going to
happen but then i asked them i'm like do
you have like cups and bowls and stuff
he's like no so i had to like go and buy
him like all this [ __ ] he like moves in
he's like gordon what do you think about
wi-fi
like what do you mean what i think about
wi-fi he goes is it worth getting i'm
like
i'm like yeah i'm like you want to like
hook up your tv and watch like you know
netflix something he goes i despise tv
i'm not going to watch it i'm like okay
i'm like well
like what if you want to have like your
phone connected to the wi-fi so you can
watch tape he goes i can just watch it
with the 5g it's free
i'm like okay
and i'm like well
what if you have a check over on a date
and she wants to watch something on on
netflix he is
good point
how much does it cost and i'm like i
don't know like 80 bucks a month he's
like okay i'll consider it
oh my god
he's like a character in a movie yeah it
really is like there's i've never even
heard of a person like him if a person
was like that they would be pretending
yes you know they're pretending to be
this stoic master who's just selfless
and dedicated to the advancement of
their students
but there's no real people like that no
that's him that's just like that's
that's insane